[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace cono Sur en esta
emisión desde Buenos Aires Argentina
nuestro tema de hoy la compleja
situación económica que atraviesa este
país si bien en 2022 la economía crecerá
por segundo año consecutivo y la
desocupación ha descendido en los
últimos dos años Argentina enfrenta
altos niveles de inflación una
degradación del mercado de trabajo y
profundas dificultades vinculadas con la
histórica relación del país con el dólar
dejando de lado Venezuela que tiene una
inflación anual por encima del 150%
argentina se posiciona como el país de
América Latina que acumula un mayor
aumento de precios en 2022 se estima que
terminará el año por encima del 100%,
una de las inflaciones más altas del
mundo
hoy ya desde pequeños los argentinos
aprenden a convivir con los constantes
aumentos de precios me compré dos
chocolates me salió 500 pesos y el año
pasado con esa plata me podría haber
comprado el doble como bien entiende
Clara la inflación es un proceso que va
ahora dando la capacidad de compra si la
inflación es superior al 30% anual las
posibilidades como tenemos Hoy casi 100%
en el año la las posibilidades de
recuperar ingreso son muy pocas
aún los hogares con ingresos fijos
trabajos estables en blanco sienten el
impacto del desfasaje inflacionario como
le sucede a la familia de Valeria que
posterga reparaciones de su casa y
ajusta consumos un Grifo sale de 25 mil
pesos el más barato una cosa así y
después los cerámicos y El albañil O sea
no no es porque
se van priorizando las necesidades más
urgentes Si ves allá Creo que está la
harina que compramos en mercado central
arriba
no compramos ni ni pizza ni pre pizza ni
tarta ni o sea todo sea más acá
[Música]
la carne usamos la carne más económica
tipo para
cocinarla varias horas
casas como la de Valeria han constituido
históricamente el corazón de la clase
media Argentina que durante décadas
estuvo consolidada y distinguida al país
de gran parte de la región pero cada vez
está más debilitada y las perspectivas
no son buenas porque la inflación es un
proceso difícil de desmontar como
explica Ricardo Delgado A ver no hay
magia la inflación no se va a
desaparecer o no va a bajar
dramáticamente de la noche a la mañana
en la Argentina Es probable que
requiera un programa de tres o cuatro
años para que la inflación se acerque a
los a los estándares internacionales en
torno al 10% anual Mientras tanto el
gobierno va aplicando medidas de
contención acuerdos parciales de precios
en algunos sectores tasas de interés
altas para intentar absorber pesos y
estrategias para consolidar las reservas
de dólares por ejemplo ofreciendo un
beneficio para el principal sector
exportador del país el de la soja el
sector tenía frenadas las exportaciones
porque los dólares que traía al país se
cambiaban a la tasa oficial de unos 170
pesos mientras que los dólares paralelos
están por encima de los 300 pesos
finalmente el gobierno les ofreció una
tasa de 230 pesos por dólar hasta fin de
año con la expectativa de que ingresen
unos 3.000 millones de dólares durante
diciembre
en este contexto todos los actores
económicos según su poder relativo el
campo empresario sindicatos bancos
exportadores importadores buscan obtener
las mejores condiciones son decisiones
racionales a nivel individual pero no
necesariamente a nivel general El punto
es que esas racionalidades micro
terminan haciendo una gran
irracionalidad Macro ese es el problema
de la Argentina no terminamos de
encontrar de hacer el clic que nos
permita darle a la Macro la racionalidad
que tenemos desde la micro Y para
justamente darle racionalidad a la Macro
se necesitan acuerdos se necesitan
consensos se necesitan reglas de juego
el caso de la distribución de los
dólares en la economía es paradigmático
esta fábrica de hilados sintético creció
desde 2019 en parte Gracias al respaldo
a la industria Nacional del actual
gobierno pasó de 90 a 190 empleados e
invirtió cerca de 2 millones de dólares
en Nueva maquinaria pero se encuentra en
una situación crítica porque no tiene
acceso a dólares a tipo de cambio
oficial para poder importar la materia
prima esencial para su producción es
resultado de una estrategia del gobierno
para preservar las Divisas pero en este
caso como en el de otras industrias
señalan que no debería alcanzar a
insumos básicos Para no afectar la
producción y el empleo me sobra un
montón de gente que no tiene que hacer
Entonces ya hemos adelantado vacaciones
pero si esto se prolonga Lamentablemente
va a terminar en suspensiones y después
despido no tengo mucha vuelta Luciano
balfione pide que le den acceso a
dólares a valor oficial para poder
importar o sugiere que directamente se
imite a todo el sector a buscar dólares
a precio de Mercado pero advierte que
eso terminaría impactando en los precios
de las prendas que se fabrican con sus
hilados que ya han sufrido aumentos
importantes y eso alimentaría aún más la
inflación hoy el margen de acción para
el gobierno es mínimo y no solo por las
condiciones económicas locales e
internacionales sino también por las
políticas a las diferencias al interior
de la coalición de gobiernos al hecho de
que apenas le queda un año de gestión si
no renueva mandato en 2023 además los
diálogos entre los diferentes partidos
políticos son demasiado débiles como
para que se vislumbre algún posible
acuerdo de largo plazo algo que muchos
creen que es la verdadera solución para
los problemas del país gracias por
acompañarnos en esta edición de enlace
cono Sur Los invito ahora a seguir con
la programación de France 24